[Music]  Kylie Jenner is not shy about showing  off her curves  the reality star was spotted filming her  new series life of Kylie in LA this week  sporting a revealing look a black sports  bra and skin-tight bicycle shorts I'm  having so much fun I feel like I'm  getting into so many cool beauty things  I'm excited about it 19 year old Kylie  had her tiny waist on display for a  shopping trip with her bestie and now  co-star Jordan woods every day it's  something new  Kyle Isel has no problem putting her fit  figure and life on full display her  Instagram is filled with racy pics like  this shot of her seductively posing in a  sheer one-piece swimsuit and coming this  July fans will get an even closer look  into Kylie's world there's two sides of  me there's an image that I feel  constantly pressure to keep up with and  who I really am around my friends  [Music]